قالت تسلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا في
اقليم دنياس ان الجيش الروسي والقوات
المتحفه مع تواصل استعاده مناطق من دنياتك
كانت تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني بينما اكد
الجيش الاوكراني انه صدق ثماني محاولات
روسيه للتقدم في دوم بس للمتابعه ينضم
الينا من كراماتوست مراسل الجزيره عامر
لافي ومن دنياتك الخاضع للسيطره الروسيه
مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر معك سلام واخر
التطورات الميدانيه وتبادل للاسرى اعلن
عنه قبل قليل بين الجانبين الاوكراني
والروسي ماذا في التفاصيل
اي سي في الجانب الميداني القصف المتبادل
لا يزال مستمرا منذ صباح اليوم وان بشكل
متقطع خاصه عند الحدود الفاصله بين
الجيشين الاوكراني والروسيه اليوم قالت
السلطات المحليه هنا في دانياتك ان هذا
القصف اسفر عن مقتل مدني في قذيفه استهدفت
منزلا بحسب السلطات في حي اكياسكي في
مدينه دمياط بالنسبه لتبادل الاسرى وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اكدت حدوث عمليات التبادل
واكتفت بالقول انها تمكنت من اعاده تسعه
من جنود الجيش الروسي الى الاراضي الروسيه
وتم نقلها هؤلاء من منطقه التبادل الى
مستشفيات في موسكو لتلقي العلاج في خصوص
الاوضاع الميدانيه ابرز ما ورد اليوم على
لسان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت الوزاره
انه وحداتها قد تمكنت من صدها جماعه في
التقطي له جونسكو ودونيتسكو حددت في منطقه
دونيت قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت
استعاده بعض المناطق التي كانت خاضعه
لسيطرتها لكن الجيش السوري الجيش الروسي
والقوات المواليه له تمكنت من صد هذه
الاشهر الهجمات واوقعت خسائر كبيره ايضا
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع ايجو الكونال
تحدث عن تدميري مخازن اسلحه في زبروجيا
وتحدث عن استهداف منظومه هايمرس وايضا
مخازن لصواريخ هايمارس في منطقه تاخير سون
وتحدث ايضا عن استهدافي وتدمير ما وصفتها
وزاره الدفاع بقوه بمراكز التحكم
والمجموعات التكتيكيه التابعه للجيش
الاوكراني على اي حال نستمع سويه لابرز ما
ورد على لسان المتحدث باسم او وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ايجار
في محوري
محاوله العدو للهجوم في اتجاه نفوسكوي في
جمهورته الشعبيه واسقطت منظومات الدفاع
الجوي ثلاثه طائرات بدون طيار في منطقه
تشرفوني شيبان في منطقه يخرسون خلال يوم
واحد واعترضنا اربعه صواريخ من نظامه
هيمارس وفي جنوب دونيه حول العروس سعاده
المواقع التي فقدها في منطقتين بجمهوريه
الشعبيه وادت ضربته المدفعيه واعمال
المجموعات الهجوميه الى عوده وحدات القوات
المسلحه الاخرانيه الى مواقعها الاصليه
اتحول اليك عامر لافي في كراماتورس ماذا
عن الصوره الميدانيه من الجانب الاوكراني
عامر
المعارك على طول خطوط المواجهه في دونيسكو
في لوغاز هذا ما تاكده القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت عن
صدق قواتها لتفمان محاولات تقدم من جانب
القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه تبقى طبعا يعني
نقطه طيبه موت وافدي يبقى هما الاسخن في
هذه النقاب نقاط المواجهه المستمره تحاول
القوات الروسيه وفقا لمصادرنا التقدم في
مخموت من الجزء الشمالي او من المحور
الشمالي الشرقي من سوليدار وايضا من
المحور الجنوبي من القرى الجنوبيه لمخموت
لكنها تؤكد طبعا بانه لا يوجد اي تقدم على
الارض وانها وقعت الكثير من الخسائر ايضا
نفس الشيء بخصوص محور افدي يبقى في جنوب
تونس والتي تتحدث القوات الروسيه عن تقدم
هناك لكن قوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها تصب
كل هذه المحاولات وتوقع الكثير من الخسائر
بلتوريد ارقام عن كثير من اعداد القتلى
والجرحى في صفوف الق الا روسيه وليس فقط
على محور دمباز وان وايضا في زمروجا وفي
خارجيه وفي كل المناطق على سبيل المثال
البيان قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه تحدث عن
اصابه اكثر من 50 جندي روسي باصابات
متفاوته في استهدافه في مخزن مستودع
للاسلحه في زباروديا ومستودع اخر ايضا في
احدى نواحي زبرجه قالت بانه اسفر عن همم
اصابه تقريبا 130 من الجنود الروس في هذا
الاطار تتحدث همم القياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه عن همم شيء جرى في مقاطعه
لوغانس وهو ان القوات الروسيه بدات بتحويل
الكثير من المستشفيات هناك المستشفيات
المدنيه الى مستشفيات عسكريه وبالتالي
هناك ازمه لدى الناس المدنيين في تلقي
الخدمه الطبيه بسبب تحويل هذه المستشفيات
الى عسكريه بسبب الاصابات البليغه
والكثيره في صفوف القوات الروسيه على حد
وصف بيان قياده اركان المواد الاوكرانيه
همم حاكم لوغانس ال سي حدث اليوم عن
المواجهات هناك وقال بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحرز تقدما وان كان بطيئا
وتحدث ايضا على القصف الغير متوقف للمدن
والبلدات التي تمت استعادتها مؤخرا في هذه
المقاطع في لوس شكرا لكما من كريماتس عامر
لافي ومن دنيا سلام خضر